yesterday i did a segment on the show
where i ran through an email exchange i
had
with an anti-vaccine conspiracy theorist
and um she disappeared after i asked for
the documents she claimed to have and i
got a bunch of different emails and
voicemails about this and i'm going to
play a voicemail for you that raises an
issue that's actually a much bigger
issue
than just with anti-vaxx folks and it's
a delicate issue it relates to mental
illness
let's take a listen to this and then i
wanna i wanna treat it with with the
seriousness that it uh that that it
should
be treated with take a listen hi david
this is collins big fan has been a
member of your show since the start of
coven listened
every single day so your streams are
always released in times of crisis like
january 6
which is much appreciated but my
question recently you had an email
correspondence with an individual named
amy who is deep into a number of
conspiracies particularly around coveted
vaccines
so my sister suffers from a number of
mental disabilities and also speaks of
these issues in a similar manner
so what do you feel if anything we can
do as a society to reach out to
loved ones friends acquaintances
strangers even who believe in this
false reality and also we ever take a
hard look at the
mental illness conspiracy connection and
then the impact it has on our political
course
thank you this is a really good
voicemail
and a serious topic and you know this
has come up before on the show where
we will look at some of these wildly
religious zealots and sometimes they'll
call into the show
and sometimes i i do get uncomfortable
and will get away
from reviewing some of their content
because it comes clear that
they do seem to be suffering from some
kind of of severe mental illness and
without diagnosing anyone
with some of these extreme religious
zealots who call me about
biden is the the riding in on a white
horse and this prophecy and that
at a certain point it sort of becomes
indistinguishable from someone having a
psychotic episode
someone suffering from paranoid
delusions etc
we've talked with experts on conspiracy
theories and conspiracism on the program
before
and they've said that yes mental illness
emotional trauma um unmedicated
undiagnosed mental illness
there is a significant interplay between
that and people who go
down the so-called rabbit hole really
deeply with a lot of this stuff
and unfortunately from from our
standpoint when we're
observing anti-vaxx ideas that are out
there
it can be difficult to to to determine
what is what
there's no question that with a lot of
extreme thinking so thinking not just
oh vaccines can have side effects but
they're very safe
and if you have side effects here right
like going to this extreme of
the vaccines are killing people you're
part of the cover-up and that's part of
the cover-up and
all this different stuff um their
emotional trauma and things going on in
people's lives can play a big role in
people
falling for that there's many examples i
i know of people
um who uh let's see how i can even say
this
these are folks folks i grew up with
actually who
after a traumatic event of different
kinds in
in one case it was a sexual assault in
another case it was
another type of family trauma they
became
extreme when it comes to diet
to the point where they were hopping
between
extreme diets one where you only ate
fruit
like a lunch could be like a dozen
bananas or something like that um
to another diet of only okay different
things that doesn't matter what the
specifics are
and the sort of connection to the trauma
is very very clear
and much the same way that sometimes
after trauma
some people simply become depressed or
some people become anxious or some
people develop agoraphobia they don't
want to leave their house
there's no question that if opportunity
strikes and circumstances are right
that same type of trauma or simply
long-term
undiagnosed mental illness can make it
so that oh
it's the it's vaccines that that's the
topic right now well
i'm going to jump into the vaccine
conspiracy theories or whatever the case
may be
so unfortunately this relates to to far
bigger issues
number one it relates to lack of access
to mental health resources and also
stigma around mental health
uh services that that really shouldn't
be there
and this can apply to any kind of
conspiracism conspiratorial thinking
paranoid delusions
psychotic episodes all of this type of
stuff from the standpoint of policy
you know it's very difficult to have to
evaluate uh the the sort of
um emotional state of individuals when
we are debunking
this uh flawed thinking so it's a really
really tough thing
i i think it's important to handle it
delicately and we don't want to further
stigmatize mental illness but there is
no question that
you know when i get 20 anti-vax emails
um some portion of those people are
are less people that are truly
researching and and convinced about this
particular thing
this is just the current outward
manifestation
of what could be all sorts of uh
emotional mental health and and
psychiatric issues and it is
a very complicated situation so i don't
know what else to say about it other
than
i i'm aware of this and i don't exactly
know
how to best deal with it we have a great
bonus show for you today
um we will reveal just how close
texas was during the power outage to a
power outage that could have actually
extended
into the months rather than the days
it's it's shocking what we're learning
about what's going on there
the south dakota attorney general is now
facing impeachment and calls to resign
over new evidence in a fatal uh our car
crash which we will discuss
and we didn't have time to talk about
this i do want to talk about this entire
kim jong-un
ride home on air force one thing that's
been floating around
so we will have all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show
i hope you'll sign up and grab a
membership at joinpakman.com it's cheap
it's easy you'll be supporting the show
and you'll get instant access to today's
bonus show i'll see you then